uh you know we've been talking about the
possibility
that on election day donald trump will
try to
use federal troops to intimidate voters
at polling places and it turns out that
trump may not even have to
because his own supporters are showing
up at early voting sites
and already intimidating voters we're
seeing a big advantage for democrats
in terms of absentee ballots and in
terms of early voting
and the trumpists are showing up and
doing what they can
to intimidate voters virginia uh
had its first week of early voting
groups of trump supporters
were showing up including in northern
virginia
blocking the path to the location
this was a disproportionately democratic
area of virginia
chanting four more years it actually led
to
county election officials having to
provide
escorts for voters to get past
the protesters groups of uh trump
supporters were
chanting four more years and doing all
sorts of other stuff we have video
this was captured by maryland
photographer anthony tillman
and you'll see the crowd carrying trump
signs flags
chanting right outside the building
making it difficult to get in and out
now remember the legality
of this is unclear because
electioneering
at polling places isn't allowed what
counts
as being at the polling place depends on
the state
in virginia my understanding is that
it's within 40 feet of the front doors
it certainly seems as though in this
video the protesters are within 40 feet
of the front doors
[Music]
[Applause]
four years four more years
[Music]
[Applause]
so as you can see trumpists creating a
blockade
chanting blocking the path in now there
are people who are saying including the
virginia republican party which i'll
get to there are people saying this is
an intimidation
only the most triggered snowflake
could consider this intimidation anybody
can just walk by
guys this is not how elections are
supposed to happen
there is not supposed to be
electioneering at polling places if you
are
just to pick something if you're a 70
year old woman
showing up to vote for biden and you
have to weave your way through
a crowd of dozens of trumpists by the
front door
chanting blocking the path holding signs
screaming that is not how elections are
supposed to happen in the united states
there are election officials in fairfax
county virginia
and uh who are admitting that voters and
even some of the poll workers
felt intimidated by this crowd and again
they required
escorts to get people in and out of the
building
and again it's illegal in virginia you
can't be within 40 feet
of the precinct in virginia now
the virginia republican party just
mocked the entire thing
the new york times put out a story about
this and
the virginia republican party tweeted
the story with the message
quick someone called the wambulance
which is just you know the height of
maturity
and interestingly some of the voters who
were
in line to vote were asked why are you
standing in such a long line to vote in
person
you could vote by mail you're standing
in line to vote early
in person and voters said
we don't trust the mail take a look at
this report from cnn all right jim i
just want to step out here so you can
see just how far
back this line goes i mean it's about
two football fields here and keep in
mind this is a
huge government building in fairfax
virginia the biggest county here
and they're at capacity inside of the
building now they're trying to keep
people here
outside socially distant but as you can
see it is
difficult particularly given the fact
that this line is so enormous and once
they actually get
inside of the building there is still at
least an
hour and a half wait now we have talked
to several of these voters
about why it is that they chose to show
up early uh
many of them saying they knew it was
going to be a very
big election that it was critical that
there was going to be a lot of interest
they wanted to be one of the first
people to cast their ballot
but we also heard about mistrust of the
postal service take a listen to this
because i don't trust the mail right now
that's why and so that's why you decided
if i
so this gets me to the one good thing
that i am seeing
in terms of enthusiasm it seems to be
high i've been using this phrase for a
couple of months
people might be willing to crawl over
broken glass to vote
it seems people are willing to do it and
the death of ruth bader ginsburg
tragic and may lead to one of the most
conservative supreme courts in decades
but it seems to have increased
enthusiasm on the left
donations to democrats have been pouring
in
since the past passing of ruth bader
ginsburg and
if anything like this happens when you
are voting
i want to hear about it if you can
safely take video
take video and get it to me we will be
talking
about the voter intimidation that takes
place keep an eye out and let me know
what you see
if you are anything like me you probably
aren't thrilled with the idea of going
into
a doctor's office right now and
thankfully there's a
practical and affordable way to take
control of your health
and get personalized care from the
comfort of your home it's a service
called
steady md they're one of our sponsors
you take a quiz
you get matched with a licensed primary
care physician
who understands your health needs you
have a one hour video call with your new
doctor
you establish a meaningful relationship
with them and after that
your doctor is available to you anytime
by text phone or video chat this is not
a random doctor on call
each doctor at steady md has a limited
number of patients so they actually have
time
to listen to you you get the personal
attention that you deserve
they can do almost everything an
in-person doctor can do
perform medical evaluations talk to you
about health concerns send prescriptions
to your home or local pharmacy
and anything they can't do online
they'll quickly set you up with
an in-person provider to do things like
blood tests as an example
you don't need insurance it's only 99
bucks a month with
no other fees or copays there are so
many
practical advantages to using steady md
for primary care
and it's also so much more affordable
go to steadymd.com slash pacman to take
the free quiz
see which doctor is right for you i took
their quiz they matched me with
a doctor who specializes in my
particular health needs and situation
the doctor they gave me is a really
perfect fit for me and my medical needs
there's no risk no commitment to get
started just click the link right
underneath this video